dans leurs villages isolés ivan et série
pensait être loin de la guerre jusqu'à
ce qu'il soit rattrapé par la réalité
dimanche dans la journée le système de
défense aérien a battu un missile dont
les débris ont endommagé les habitations
alentour
s'il ya des
petits bouts d'une
excellente
à quelques mètres de là des hommes
inquiet pour le sort de leurs villages
ont mis en place un périmètre de
sécurité est creusé des tranchées
[Musique]
les checkpoints comme celui ci se
multiplient dans tout le secteur le
travail de simples bénévoles
même les enfants prennent part à
l'effort
mais
une détermination et un sentiment
antirusse désormais palpable dans toute
l'ukraine